Das Tolle, Andi, ich finde deine Stimmung, während ich hier versuche die Technik aufzubauen, ist immer so Wut. Es ist Wut, es ist vor allem auch so ein, das muss doch leichter gehen, es muss schneller gehen. Also ich habe beim ersten Mal, erinnerst du dich vielleicht noch, als du das erste Mal die Technik aufgebaut hast, war ich zurückgelehnt, freundlich, erwartend zwar. Und snackend. Ich habe mich auch gefreut, dass es gleich losgeht, aber mittlerweile, wo ich merke, du wirst nicht schneller bei dem Pranzensprozess.
Im Gegenteil, du wirst langsamer
und verzweifelter auch so ein bisschen.
Die Haare immer zerzaust, da immer mehr so auch
Kohle im Gesicht, Dreck im Gesicht, wo man sich fragt,
wo kommt das denn, du musst so ein Mikrofon einstecken.
Du bist in so einem, das muss doch schneller gehen
und ich bin aber zu faules Selbst.
Ja, voll. Du bist zwischendrin gefangen.
Und man merkt, ich will mich mehr aufregen, kann er aber nicht,
weil er das dann hätte selber machen müssen.
Dass man jemandem mal irgendwas zuguckt, was er nicht kann oder sie nicht kann und man schaut sich an und denkt sich, fuck, aber ich bin zu faul, das selbst übernehmen. Man steht aber auch so Stirngerunzelt und Kopfschüttelt daneben, aber auch nicht so laut, dass sie jetzt sagt, hey komm, willst du das einfach selber machen und dann will man es auch nicht machen. Hey, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von Das Podcast UFO!
UFO!
Du bist mir Warner-Singend hier reingekommen.
Das ist einfach für mich geiles.
Bei uns klingt es wie Futurama, bei uns klingt es auch in unseren Comic-Stimmen.
Aber ist Kurt Cobain so in Proberaum gegangen und hat gesagt, also ich stelle mir ein Lied so vor. Den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den. 121, lass uns einfach einstellen. Lass uns einfach, weil wir machen zeitlose Folgen. Ein Konzept dieses Podcasts, das kann man ja mal sagen nach 121 Folgen, ist, dass wir zeitlos sind. Ich glaube, die meisten haben es schon rausgefunden. Wir reden nicht über aktuelle Ereignisse, ausser manchmal, weil wir auch kein Konzept haben, dass wir immer brechen. Das ist auch die Idee. Aber warum nicht einfach die Zahlen einstellen, einfach sagen, heute ist die Folge meinetwegen Bilanzbuchhaltung, das ist unser Thema, das reden wir. Du willst so den Raubkatzen übergehen, wie bei Mac, bei den Betriebssystemen. Aber ich glaube, all diese Systeme haben uns gelehrt, dass Zahlen im Endeffekt doch das Beste sind. Ja, ja, war Sierra Leone jetzt besser als El Capitan? Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Ich denk mir so, okay, du hast die schnellste Katze, Gepard, bis wann hebst du dir den auf? Weil irgendwann denkst du, okay, entweder wir nehmen jetzt irgendwelche obskuren Lüstenmäuse. Der PC ist doch schon ziemlich schnell. Nenn ihn doch letztendlich Gepard. Aber geht es nur um Schnelligkeit letztendlich oder geht es auch um Wendigkeit oder man weiß einfach nicht. Punkte, Anzeige, keine Ahnung. Hier bei der BTF,
mega nervig, heißen alle Server wie
berühmte Regisseure, aber nicht wie
die Nachnamen der berühmten Regisseure,
wie Aronofsky,
Jodorowsky, nein, hier heißen die
die Vornamen, die Vornamen
von berühmten Regisseure, also ein Server
heißt Tim. Tim Burton.
Von Tim Burton, ja. Und die ganze
Zeit geht es so weiter, Quentin, Chris, halt und man fragt sich die ganze Zeit. Wim gibt es auch. Mark. Vor allem irgendwann kann man anfangen, irgendwelche Vornamen zu behaupten und einfach alle anderen spielen mit. Und denken sich so, ja klar, Zacharias, alle seine Filme habe ich geliebt. Stanley, klar kenne ich seine Filme. Wir hatten gerade über Matrix gesprochen, kurz. Ja, weil ich es lustig fand, darüber nachzudenken, weil du heute meinst, du hast dich in den Server gehackt, da musst du nur auf Datei exportieren klingen. Und ich fand es lustig, wenn man überlegt, angenommen die Macher von Matrix haben keine Ahnung von Hacken und so und glauben einfach, dass Datei exportieren, auf Festplatte exportieren, der krasseste Hackerscheiße ist.
Die ganze Zeit spannende Musik, man sieht in dunklen Gemäuern, sieht man so Leute sitzen, aber eigentlich drücken sie die ganze Zeit nur auf Dateispeichern. Vor allem, also ich meine, Matrix ist ein Film von einem Hacker, der in die Zukunft reist, grob, jetzt einmal grob zusammengefasst. Das Letzte, was du in der Zukunft sein willst, ist Hacker.
Ja.
Weil wirklich der einzige Berufsstand, den man in der Zukunft so gar nicht gebrauchen kann, weil alle Betriebssysteme sind neu, die Programmiersprachen sind neu, die Computereingabe ist neu, es gibt ein USB-4, what? So als Hacker bist du völlig... Die krasseste Zahl, die dir eingefallen ist. Es gibt USB-G-Part. Du bist völlig unbrauchbar. Ja. Keine Ahnung, du bist von mir aus Polizist, Soldat, Schreiner. Kannst du alles noch was in der Zukunft mit anfangen? Das Einzige, was du wirklich nicht brauchen kannst in der Zukunft, sind Hacker oder Computerspezialisten. Spielt Matrix in der ... Sorry. Na ja. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wo man es in den Filmen kann. Eigentlich ... Kannst du dich an den Filmen erinnern? Immer wenn ich über Filme nachdenke, denke ich, ich habe keinen gesehen. Ich erinnere mich an grobe Plotpoints, an die Szene in dem Chesterfield-Sessel mit dem blauen und roten Pille erinnere mich dran, an den Sessel erinnere mich sehr gut dran, an diesen Tunnel, ich sehe so schemenhaft so ein paar Ausstürte. Lass uns heute mal einen spontan Antennen Nebukadnezar machen. Wir sprechen über Matrix, weil, es ist eine interessante Frage, ob die in die Zukunft reisen oder nicht,
weil die bauen ja die
Matrix, programmieren die ja, können die
sich ja ausdenken, wie die aussieht.
Aber die haben dafür etwas
gewählt, wie es war, bevor
die Maschinen übernommen haben.
Nicht so, wie es jetzt ist,
weil jetzt haben die ja Raumschiffe, die fliegen,
aber in der Matrix, das ist ja
die normale Echtzeitwelt, 90er Jahre, Büro,
da gibt es keine Raumschiffe,
die fliegen. Das heißt, die haben sich entschieden,
Also, Weil jetzt haben die ja Raumschiffe, die fliegen. Aber in der Matrix, das ist ja die normale Echtzeitwelt, 90er Jahre Büro, da gibt es keine Raumschiffe, die fliegen. Das heißt, die haben sich entschieden, au, jetzt sind wir gerade 2108 und die Maschinen haben schon lange dominiert. Wir entscheiden uns jetzt die Matrix aber zu schreiben in 1993, wo es noch diese Clubhandys gab. Das ist genau die richtige Zeit. Ich hänge noch ein bisschen an dem Vorspiel Antenne Nebukadnezar fest.
Da bin ich noch nicht hinweggekommen.
Andere Frage, Dark, die deutsche Serie, spielt im Jahre 2019.
Herzlich willkommen zu unserer neuen Rubrik Stephan Spoiler Dark.
In jeder Folge wird Dark ein Spoiler. Ja, ich weiß, alle haben es verkannt.
Jeder.
Nee, aber es heißt, er spielt im Jahre 2019.
Und man weiß nicht genau, warum. Weil, also glaube, es geht ja um Zeitreisen und so. Und ich glaube, die sind von 86 angefangen und haben dann gesagt, also dann geht es ja darum, diese 33 Jahre, in denen immer was passiert. Und dann, warum, weil die Gegenwartssession ist im Jahre 2019. Und das geht in meinen Kopf absolut nicht rein, warum die sich für dieses Jahr entschieden haben. Das ist so wie eine Serie 2012 spielen zu lassen, wo ich nicht genau weiß, warum jetzt genau? Man hat einen Überblick über das Jahr, okay. Ja, vor allem, wenn dann irgendwie das Set geflutet wird oder das Studio abbrennt und die Produktion sich verschiebt, dann so, fuck, Leute, fuck, wir holen uns selbst ein, was, scheiße, wir können jetzt nicht alle noch mal Voice-Over'n, 2020, wir können das nicht
noch mal ändern, es kann nicht jetzt spielen.
Apropos Schnitt, ich habe heute ein Video gesehen, dass Star Wars Episode IV noch mal komplett
umgeschnitten wurde vor der Veröffentlichung.
Oh, und zwar das Video heißt, Star Wars was saved in the edit.
Genau, und ein grosser Plotpunkt, der zum Beispiel gefehlt hat in der ursprünglichen Fassung war, dass am Ende die Rebellen den Todesstern angreifen, ohne dass der Todesstern eine konkrete Gefahr darstellt. Im neuen, also im finalen Edit geht er ja langsam um den Mond herum, um dann die Rebel-Basis angreifen zu können. Man hat die ganze Zeit die Bedrohung, weil die müssen den jetzt umbringen, sonst sterben alle auf dem Planeten. Ja, wie in vier. Gab's einfach nicht. Es wurde nicht so gedreht und tatsächlich wurde dieser gesamte Plotpoint erzählt durch Offscreen-Texte. Wenn man sich das anschaut, alle Texte, es fällt gar nicht auf. Ich habe diesen Film achtundundmal gesehen, das ist mir aufgefallen. Es ist unglaublich. Und eine andere Sache, die da erklärt wird, war, dass ganz am Anfang des Films Luke schon gezeigt wurde, bevor er überhaupt eine Rolle spielt. Das heißt, man sieht die ganze Zeit die Raumschlacht mit Darth Vader und dem Schiff, dem Diplomaten-Schiff, wo Leia drauf ist und das gefangen genommen wird und man sieht das Schießen. Und man ist aber schon die ganze Zeit bei Luke, der auf den Himmel guckt, was eigentlich ganz geil ist, der in den Himmel guckt und sieht oben, wie im Raum quasi ein Kampf stattfindet, und er nicht weiss, worum es geht. Und irgendwann landen die dann bei ihm, und dieses Video kritisiert total, dass die Andauer dazwischen schneiden wollte, also Luke es dazwischen schneiden wollte. Und tatsächlich dachte ich mir aber eigentlich ganz cool, dass man beide Storylines erzählt, die dann zusammengeführt werden, relativ am Anfang ja noch, in den ersten paar Minuten. Ich glaube, du findest es aber nur cool, weil du schon weißt, wer Luke Skywalker ist.
Wenn du den Film noch nicht gesehen hast und nicht weißt, wer es ist, ist total strange. Es wirkt wirklich merkwürdig. Aber das stimmt, wir merken das auch bei guter Arbeit, dass im Schnitt, also im Schnitt muss der Film oder der Sketch in dem Fall nochmal komplett umgemuddelt werden, weil es einfach ganz anders ist. Zum Beispiel auch Dinge, die, wenn man den Film kennt, völlig selbstverständlich sind, wie zum Beispiel, dass die Macht als
Konzept das erste Mal von Obi-Wan
erklärt wird, war in der ursprünglichen
Fassung nicht so. Da hat man erst den Force-Joke
von Darth Vader gesehen. Force-Joke,
nicht Joke.
Der Force-Joke.
Kommt ein Rabbi,
kommt ein Rabbi,
jemand mit der Macht und Jedi.
Ihr findet diesen Witz lustig. Du hast von allen Sith-Techniken, hast du dir den Force-Joke ausgedacht. Den Force-Joke. Das ist meine Spezialität, so der eine Sith in der Ecke, der so mega unerfolgreich ist, kein großes Castle irgendwo auf Musterfahrt, sondern einfach die Force-Jokes perfektioniert hat. Ja, aber für uns völlig selbstverständlich, dass Obi-Wan natürlich erklärt, die Macht, die alles zusammenhält und nicht erst Darth Vader. Aber auch hier habe ich mir gedacht, ganz geil, wenn man erst, das ist ja der grössere What-the-Fuck-Moment, wenn dann dieser schwarze Ritter plötzlich anfängt, jemanden Force zu joken und danach wird es erklärt. Fände ich auch interessant. Ich dachte mir immer, ganz in der ersten Szene von Darth Vader, wie er durch diesen Korridor läuft, wo die ganzen Rebellen erschossen wurden, wirkt er ja einen Rebellen mit der Hand. Nee, er hält den hoch. Richtig, mit der Hand. Wo ich mir immer dachte, Darth Vader, bekannt und berühmt für seinen Force-Joke, macht den Hirn gerade nicht, sondern macht ihn manuell. Wo ich mir dachte, ah, ich verstehe, das haben die gemacht, damit die am Anfang noch nicht verrät, dass es Macht gibt. Aber anscheinend nicht, anscheinend kam diese Idee des Force-Jokes erst später. Übrigens ist das eine Folge wirklich gerade in einem spannenden Spannungsfeld. Ich habe den Film schon gesehen, ich habe den bereits am Montag gesehen. Episode 8. Und Florian hat den noch nicht gesehen. Ich werde ihn auch wahrscheinlich erst die nächsten Monate noch nicht sehen, weil er keine Zeit hat. Aber das ist total spannend, weil ich wollte sogar mit dir darüber reden, du hast ihn aber noch nicht gesehen. Und ich war in der Pressevorführung, was mindblowing war, weil ich bin es gewohnt, die neuen, sieben und Rogue One und so habe ich so angespannt, ich kann es nicht haben, dass du auch nur überhaupt nichts darüber sagst, ich weiß alles, weil nebenbei, wenn du nur sagst, am Ende haben alle applaudiert, denke ich mir, das will ich nicht wissen, ich will das alles nicht wissen. Genau das weiss ich ja. Das will ich dir auch nicht sagen. Es gibt auch nichts getwittert oder so, weil viele haben ja geschrieben, wow, Megafilm, furchtbare Filme, haben alles geschrieben.
Halt die... weiss ich nicht!
Hör auf oder nicht! Ich will nicht wissen, was andere twittert. Nee. Spoiler nicht indirekt. Ich spoiler nicht, ich sag nur, was andere gespoilert haben. Deswegen habe ich beides gesagt, weil ich nicht sagen wollte, was passiert. Ja, aber jetzt weiß ich, dass Menschen eine Meinung zu dem Film haben, was auch schon was aussagt. Naja, und dann war ich halt ... Ich bin halt gewohnt, mit Leuten da zu sitzen,
die ausrasten bei allem, die applaudieren, wenn am Anfang ein Lucasfilm kommt und so
weiter.
Am Anfang kommt Lucasfilm, sorry!
Halt, nein!
Sorry!
Und dann saß ich halt ... Geht der Vorhang auf oder bleibt der Vorhang zu im Kino?
Bleibt die ganze Zeit zu, bleibt die ganze Zeit zu.
Fuck, Alter, was den 3D-Effekt ein bisschen zerstört.
Rechts von mir saß irgendwie so eine FAZ-Frau, mit ihrer ... Wirklich so eine Klischee-Journalistin,
eine Klischee-Fögetomistin, mit so einer ... Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, diese
Vielen Dank. Rechts von mir saß eine FAZ-Frau mit ihrer ... Wirklich so eine Klischee-Journalistin, eine Klischee-Fögetomistin,
mit so einer ... ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, diese Brillen,
die schon aussagen, dass man was Besseres ist, nämlich diese ovalen.
Dicker Rahmen und so eierförmig, also so augenförmig. Aber horizontal oder vertikal eierförmig?
Keine Ahnung.
Nee, schon vertikal, horizontal, Entschuldigung. Ja. Horizontal und dann aber wie augenförmig halt, weißt du, wie diese ägyptischen Schriftzeichen. Ihr habt ein Bild davon. Ja, ja. So dicke Rahmen, so eine Hornbrille. Ey, dafür wurden Vorurteile erfunden, dass wenn du sagst, ne Klischee für Tangerlisten, hätte gereicht. Dass man dann nicht mehr die Brille erkennt. Ja, hätte gereicht. Und die saß dann da, mir gelangweilt die ganze Zeit, und links von mir saß jemand, der die Schule geschwänstert hat, weil es halt morgens um zwölf Uhr war, diese Vorstellung, und der hat so einen eigenen Star-Wars-Blog gemacht und war halt genauso angespannt wie ich die ganze Zeit im Film, was ganz interessant war. Auch ein spannendes Spannungsverhältnis, in dem man sich da befand. Ich hab total Angst davor, den im Kino zu sehen, weil ich ertrage es ja nicht, wenn Leute reden im Film. Ey, aber bei der Premiere kannst du es vergessen.
Das denk ich mir immer.
Das ist ganz geil.
Ich hoffe, ich baue wirklich, und das ist wirklich so meine letzte Funken Hoffnung in die Menschheit, dass man zumindest bei einer Premiere, wenn man das erste Mal den lang erwarteten Film, auf den alle seit zwei Jahren warten, dann zumindest die Klappe hält. Aber es gibt Leute, es gibt diese ...
Wuh!
Ja, ja, ich hab gar nichts gegen diese emotionalen Ausrufe oder Lachen oder oder so, kein Problem. Auch die Wow kann nicht mitleben. Aber es gibt ja... Ihr habt Flur die nicht gesehen. Wie ein 80-Jähriger sich vorstellt, dass heute die 13-Jährigen im Club jubeln, sondern gerade die Faust so leicht hochgenommen. Wow!
So wie Angela Merkel
bei einem Länderspiel jubelt. So hast du gerade gejubelt.
Es gibt ja Scheiss-Nerds
und es gibt gute Nerds. Wir sind ja
mittlerweile so tief in der Nerdkultur
drin, dass es schon Facetten von Nerds
gibt. Früher gab es den Nerd, jetzt
wird alles bunter. Jetzt wir gehen rein
und das Spektrum wird größer. Und es gibt
die Nerds, die Respekt haben für andere Nerds, die noch einen Hauch sozialer Kompetenz in sich haben und die verstehen, hey, wir haben alle lange auf den Film gewartet, wir haben alle Bock drauf, lass den einfach alle zusammen genießen und wir halten alle die Fresse. Und dann gibt's die Nerds, die reingehen mit meine 20-Punkte-Liste von Dingen, die ich erwarte in dem Film. Und dann jedes Mal... Genau, das hab ich gemacht. Jedes Mal, nee, aber was du nicht gemacht hast, ist dann während des Films zu sagen, ja, habe ich doch gesagt, ja, aber könnte es jetzt nicht doch sein, dass Ray, ne, ne, ne, ja, aber vielleicht hat Kylo doch, achte mal darauf, guck mal da, hast du das gesehen? Ich habe so Angst, dass die neben mir sitzen und ich sie einfach ... Ich habe wirklich, es ist genau das Fuchsproblem, es ist dieses Fuchsding, dass ich Angst habe, dass ich wirklich die reflexartig schlage einfach. Oder erwürge aus dem Affekt. Verstehen Sie nicht ganz das Fuchsproblem jetzt? Ich wurde mal beim Joggen von einem Fuchs gebissen. Deshalb war das, dass ich das weiss. Schau in die Puffopedia unter das Fuchsphänomen, das FF-Fuchsphänomen. Und danach hatte ich immer Angst beim Joggen, dass wenn mir dieser Fuchs zu nahe kommt, ich ihn aus einem Schutzreflex tötet. Ich hatte nicht Angst davor, dass ich noch mal gebissen werde, weil das nicht so schlimm ist. Ich hatte viel mehr Angst, dass mein Körper jetzt konditioniert ist auf diesen Wildnisaspekt des menschlichen Lebens und reflexartig ihn erwürgt oder begattet oder was auch immer. Wenn man nicht aufpasst, dann hast du irgendwann so ein eigenes Leben im Wald gestartet, tötest Tiere aus Reflex, Intuition. Wer hat Liam Neeson beigebracht, sich irgendwie Glasscherben an die Hände zu binden, wenn er gegen Wölfe kämpft? Das wusste der auch nicht, dass er so was weiss. Das sind Dinge, die werden so unlockt, wenn du in der Wildnis bist. Dann kriegst du das ja nicht. Ich muss sagen, ich finde es ganz geil bei der Premiere Jubel. Ich mag das schon. Ich mag das bei normalen Filmen nicht. Ich finde das bei so Premieren und deswegen, ich mag es halt nicht, wenn man Dinge verpasst und so. Ich finde aber dieses gemeinschaftliche, wir freuen uns alle, das macht noch mehr Gänsehaut irgendwie, dieses, das ist was Besonderes jetzt. Ich habe das aber nicht gerne, wenn ich dann, weil das ist leider dann unabdingbar, man verpasst Dinge. Deswegen ist es perfekt, wie ich es gemacht habe. Aus Versehen, Pressevorführung, alle halten die Fresse, es sind 30 Journalisten in dem 1200 Mann-Mann-Saal und man kann den Film in Ruhe gucken. Und danach die Premiere, wo sich alle und meine Damen können, alle jubeln. Ich hab den Film schon gesehen, fuck it. Ich werde am Anfang auch sagen, was passiert. Ich werde aufstehen und sagen, ist er schon, ist er schon? Jetzt kann ich keinen Gag machen, weil ich will nicht so. Ich spiele eine männliche Figur mit, das ist nicht selbstverständlich. Damit! Ja, ich hab dir noch nichts gesagt, ich bin gespannt, wie wir darüber reden werden, weil ich hab dir nicht mal gesagt, ob ich einen Gutfilm oder nicht. Das heißt, auch die Aufrufe von alle Star-Wars-Fans, geht ins Kino, schaut euch an, aber haltet die Fresse und schaut euch am Donnerstag Kino Plus an, wo Stefan eingeladen ist, bei Rocket Beans, oder kann er seine komplette Expertise auch in hundert Folgen Antenne Alderaan, wir werden die nächsten sechs Folgen ausschließlich über Episode acht. Wir werden noch ein paar Antenne, naja, Antenne. Ein paar Antennes machen wir noch, Antenne Apu, Antenne Alabastia, Antenne Ast. Ich dachte, ein zweiter Star-Wars-Begriff mit A. A to D to fast. Fast. Naja. Nee, genau, das machen wir auf jeden Fall. Faktencheck. Faktencheck! Ich will ganz kurz zum Thema Faktencheck gehen, weil wir haben in der letzten Folge angesprochen, das Thema, zu dem Stefan sich sehr kontrovers geäußert hat. Und zwar ... Ich habe auch so viel Hass bekommen. Erstmal habe ich immer noch viele Geschmacks-Hass-Mails. Erreiche mich immer noch, nach wie vor. Das ist wahnsinnig, wie das ausklingt. Das klingt ... man denkt das nicht. Ausartet vor allem. Und jetzt kriegen wir halt viele ... und ich hatte recht. Wobei ... Moment, darüber möchte ich gleich sprechen. Aber es ist interessant, wie das ausklingt. Du sagst es in einer Ja, okay. Das Gesicht kenne ich. Website ist Down-Gesicht. Alles gut. Unsere Website ist übrigens immer noch down. Wirklich jetzt? Kein Scheiss? Weil ich keine Zeit habe, mich darum zu kümmern. Warum machen wir das überhaupt noch? Lass uns die Scheisse einfach lassen. Wir können heute beim Support anrufen. Aber wie das nachklingt, man macht eine Folge, redet Bullshit und vier Wochen später kriegt man noch seinen eigenen Bullshit in die Ohren geworfen. War das früher auch so, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Hitler fällt in Polen ein und Jahre später noch schreiben Leute Leserbriefe in Polen und so. Weißt du, bei uns halten wir das noch vor, als ob bei Hitler, wenn man noch 2017 über Hitler spricht, über seine Fehler. Die sind vergessen. Man hat ihm vergeben, vergessen, alle lieben Hitler. Ich persönlich habe ihm vergeben. Ich bin völlig rein mit Hitler. Vergeben und vergessen. Adi, wir sind cool. Ach, jetzt hört, gib mir nicht den Blick, als ob du, nein, theoretisch angenommen, es gibt ein Nachleben, es gibt einen Himmel, Du kommst in den Himmel und triffst Adolf Hitler, als ob du da auf ihn einreden würdest, das darfst du nicht, du hast Angriffskrieg geführt, du wirst ja sagen, Alter, komm, jetzt ist eine Zeit vergangen.
Angenommen, stell dir mal vor, man ist im Urlaub, man ist wie im Hotel, man ist für die nächsten Wochen mit diesen Menschen irgendwie, dann sieht man ein paar Menschen, mit denen man gerne Zeit verbringen würde und so, dann begrüsst man sich schon mal am Buffet und so, irgendwann spricht man sich mal zu denen und spricht mit denen, so wäre ich mit Hitler im Himmel.
Würdest du dir aufheben, Würdest du die Hitler aufheben? Nee, nee, überhaupt nicht. Gar nicht? Ich könnte nicht warten drauf. Ich würde erst so langsam Augenkontakt, immer so beim Essen, morgens und so beim Buffet stehen, da gibt es ein Buffet, natürlich gibt es im Himmel, ein Buffet ist das Beste, und dann immer so grüßen, irgendwann auch zu dem setzen und so und dann immer fragen, sorry, ich will echt nicht stören, aber ich kenne dich, ich weiß ja, du bist. Und er legt die Gabel weg, lehnt sich zurück, er weiß genau, das wird länger dauern. Er klappt die Zeit zu und macht dann diese typische Zeitungslesergeste, dieses Schütteln, wo sie dann sofort wieder zufällt. Serviert er nochmal über den Mundtupfen, lehnt sich zurück, richtet die Hose und dann. Er hat auch so einen Bademantel an, so einen blauen, so einen Baby-Butter-Blauen. Blauen Bademantel an. So einen hellblauen Bademantel. Alle haben ja mit einem hellen blauen Bademantel an. Ja, und dann fängt er an. Ach, weißt du. Und dann bin ich gelangweilt. Ich bin instant gelangweilt und will die harten Facts haben. Und zwar, was ich interessant finde, unsere Podcast-Community ist ja bekannt für harte Fakten, Objektivität und wir haben letztes Mal gesprochen über, waren, wurden Menschen früher weniger alt oder genauso alt und wir haben eine... Das war, ich hab mir so lange angehört, beim Schnitt und wir haben, also wir können einfach auch nicht diskutieren, wir haben erst, hast du mir vorgehalten, dass ich die Gründe mit reinbeziehe, dann hab ich dir zehn Minuten später vorgeworfen, dass du die Gründe mit reinbeziehen. Das war eine Katastrophe.
Also, wir haben gesagt, Menschen, meine These war, dass Menschen, der heutige Mensch und der damalige Mensch von vor, sagen wir mal, 100 Jahren, bei den gleichen Bedingungen gleich alt werden.
Flo und die war der Meinung, hat dann auch sein Pubertätsjournal herangezogen und hat gesagt, dass das nicht der Fall ist und Menschen damals auch einfach nicht so alt wurden.
So, dann wurde uns, also dann kam die Statistikfreunde unter euch, die kamen uns dann mit Median und Durchschnitt.
Der Median ist die Mitte von allen Zahlen, die untereinander geschrieben werden bei einer Statistik, dann ist der Median die mittlere Zahl, die wird angekreuzt. Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, irgendwie im Kindesalter sterben, irgendwie mit einem Alter von zwei oder keine Ahnung. Deswegen ist der Durchschnitt immer mal 28. Natürlich werden aber viele Leute auch 78, nämlich so viele, dass der Median, wenn man alle so alle Zahlen untereinander schreiben würde, die mittlere Zahl sich angucken würde, wäre das wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so. Und da hat uns jemand was geschrieben, das hat Florentin jetzt rausgesucht, hoffentlich. Florentin, wir können heute nicht schneiden, wir müssen die Folge gleich sofort hochlagen. Ich bin so dumm, ich hätte es einfach vor der Folge rausholen können. Aber auf jeden Fall haben uns mehrere Leute geschrieben, und ich wollte eigentlich zwei Kommentare vorlesen. Einer und scheiß, beide haben gesagt, sie wären irgendwie Lebensalterwissenschaftler und Bullshit. Und zwei widersprechen sich. Richtig, wir haben zwei bekommen, beide mit Kompetenz, und beide widersprechen sich. Der eine hat geschrieben, ja, es ist ein Mythos, dass Menschen früher nicht so alt wurden. Und der andere hat geschrieben, ja, unabhängig von Ernährung und sonstigen Krankheitseinflüssen ist es auch so, dass Menschen unabhängig davon immer älter werden. Aber man weiß nicht warum. Liebe Grüße aus der Altersforschung. Beide liebe Grüße, Doktor Altersforschung, hast du nicht gesehen. Wie nervig. Aber das ist Wissenschaft. Aber beide haben gesagt, dass es tatsächlich umstritten ist, glaub ich auch. So, und genau das haben wir ja auch gesagt. Wir sind ja eine Doppelmeinung. Ich möchte einfach nur sagen, deswegen sind wir, sag ich mal, vielleicht nicht so mega faktenaffin, weil es halt am Ende doch immer so der eine sagt so, der andere sagt so. Fakten sind am Ende auch einfach verschobene Meinungen. Ja, Meinungen, die sich ein bisschen durchgesetzt haben. Penetrante Meinungen. Fakten sind nur laute Meinungen. Ja, penetrante, laute Meinungen, genau, richtig. Naja, schwierige Sache. Das ist so ein heißes Eisen. Ich glaube, nach Geschmack und Evolution wirklich das dritte heiße Eisen.
Das dritte, eieieieiei, weißt du, wenn man die Hand so
neben den Hals schnimmt. Ich verstehe das.
Aber du siehst mich ja auch.
Ja, aber ich dachte eher, du machst die, ich schneide die Kehle durch, Ding.
Du meinst die, tsch, stopp, es ist heiß und ich schüttel die Hand.
Warum schüttelt man die Hand so,
wenn man sich heiß verbrannt hat?
Um direkt Luft reinzulassen.
Oh, das war auch.
Gestern dachte ich mir wirklich so, da habe ich kurz mal angehalten, da hab ich mir im Kopf vorgestellt, wie so ein Vinyl-Scratch. Kennt man ja. Wenn man irgendwie den Film anhält, dann kommt so ein ... Hallo, da bin ich. Und dann fängt dann Voice-Over an. Und gestern war so ein Moment, wo ich dachte, Voice-Over, und dann, hi, das bin ich. Wie ich in diese Situation gekommen bin, ja, ich werde es euch gleich erzählen. Weil ich habe ein Schaumbad genommen, tatsächlich, ich weiß auch nicht warum, aber du hast die Tage von, ich musste eine Mats schreiben, die nicht in der Sendung gelandet ist, da habe ich noch nicht verraten, welche Sendung, aber die wurde gekillt und da sollte ich über Schaumbäder schreiben.
In der Mittagspause, so begeisterungsfähig bin ich, bin ich dann zum Lidl gegangen, habe mir ein Schaumbad gekauft und du hast mir auch die ganze Zeit erzählt, dass du die ganze Zeit nur badest und so, du bist auch ein bisschen aufgequollen, muss man sagen, durch das ganze Baden, schwammähnlich, du hast auch so ein Dreizack in der Hand und so ein Meerjungfrauenschwanz, naja, und deswegen wollte ich das halt ganz gerne machen und ich hab halt auch so ein Brett, was man sich auf die Badewanne stellen kann, wo man dann eine Serie gucken kann oder einen Film gucken kann. Mega geil! Können wir gleich drauf kommen. Hab ich dann einen Film geguckt und dann war mir das Wasser aber ein bisschen zu kalt. Dann hab ich also heißes Wasser nachgelaufen lassen. Gute Idee. Und dann hab ich mich irgendwann so dran gewöhnt, dass das Wasser lief, hab meine Beine halt so entspannt und dann ist ein Bein halt genau in das heiße Wasser gefallen und dann beide Beine schrecken halt intuitiv hoch,
also beide so nacheinander, dadurch, dass Wasser auf meinen Laptop fällt,
wodurch ich mich noch mehr erschrecke,
wodurch mein Oberkörper aufschreckt,
worauf ich wieder mit dem Bein ins heiße Wasser komme,
wodurch mein Bein wieder zuckt, das Brett umhaut
und mein Laptop aus der Badewanne quasi wirft.
Strange. Und dachte ich mir auch so,
hey, wie ich in dieser Situation gekommen bin,
das erkläre ich euch im Podcast. Aber zum Glück ist er
nicht ins Wasser gefallen. Ja, ohne Scheiß, ey.
Das war wirklich noch Glück.
Das Lück des Tölpels.
Er fällt in den großen Wasserbottich,
der immer neben der Badewanne steht.
Nein!
Mein Tiki, mein
Satriereimer. Aber dann Gott sei Dank
in den Reiseimer daneben, der das Wasser wieder rauszieht, leider dann aber in den Wassereimer, der da noch steht. Ach Mensch. Aber du bist, das haben wir schon diskutiert tatsächlich, oft eher, du bist ein Verfechter von Licht aus, nichts in der Badewanne machen, vielleicht Musik. Ja, doch, Musik, aber ansonsten nichts in der Badewanne machen, stockdunkel und und natürlich die Rückentechnik, sich so ins Wasser legen, dass die Wasseroberfläche genau einen Kreis um dein Gesicht bildet, also dass dein kompletter Hinterkopf bis zur Stirn im Wasser ist und man so oben so rausguckt. Aber du musst an Körperspannung halten, du musst dich ja anspannen. Nee, du legst dich mit deinem Rücken auf den Boden der Badewanne. Und dann bleibst du genauso liegen, das dauert. Naja, die Füsse hängen dann halt auf der anderen Seite. Dann wäre mein ganzer, ab der Hüfte, abwärts, wäre alles im Trockenen. Naja, gut. Das ist halt dein Nachteil an deinem Körper. Aber das ist schon interessant, also Badetechniken. Weil ich bin ein abwechselnd Beine anwinkeln, Beine raus Typ. Schwimmen meinst du? Ja, also manchmal, wenn man die Beine anwinkelt, ist der ganze Oberkörper drin. Und dann grutsche ich manchmal zurück und dann kann ich die Beine raus machen. Dann sind meine Beine drin, also die Oberschenkel drin. Kleiner frecher Tipp, mal auf dem Bauch. Was? Mal schön auf dem Bauch und dann Kopf unter Wasser. Wie ist das? Und dann aber hinknien dabei, oder was? Ich passe doch nicht in die Wanne, wenn ich mich auf den Bauch lege. Und dann Kopf unter Wasser, aber dann sind meine Beine aus dem Bauch. Aber dann sind die Füsse aus dem Bauch. Du weißt jetzt, wie Muslime beten, so Knie und dann so Kopf nach unten. Das ist entspannt. Hä? Aber dann sind die Füsse aus dem Wasser. Du weißt jetzt, wie Muslime beten, so Knie und dann so Koffen. Immer wieder rein. Das ist entspannt. Hä, aber dann meinst du dann die Füsse aus dem Wasser oder was? Nein, du legst die einfach auf den Bauch. Und dann? Ja, da hinten hängt dann was raus. Ja, von mir aus kannst du auch die Knie anwinkeln. Machst du das nicht so kompliziert jetzt, aber ich meine nur. Weißt du noch mal, als wir überlegt hatten, in der WG zu ziehen, und zwar in der Comedy-WG und überall Kameras aufzustellen und das ernsthaft die ganze Zeit ins Internet zu streamen? Das war eine Zeit. Das hätte ich jetzt gern gesehen, wie wir baden. Muss man dann zensieren unseren Kram später? Es ist unfassbar, wie manchmal kleine Sachen das ganze Leben formen. Stell dir wirklich mal vor, wir hätten die letzten zwei Jahre zusammen in der WG gewohnt.
Ich glaube, erstmal diesen Podcast gäbe es nicht mehr. Ich glaube, einen von uns gäbe es nicht mehr. Ich glaube, es wäre wirklich so ein Unfall passiert in der WG. Also nicht böswillig, sondern aus so einem Ungeschick heraus. Aber jetzt mal ehrliche Einschätzung. Was meinst du, wer wem mehr auf den Sack gegangen? Ich glaube, du wärst mir mehr auf den Sack gegangen. Das glaube ich auch. Weil du so Eigenarten hast, wie keine Möbel zu besitzen und du hast strange Thesen, die dein Leben einschränken und die meins zwangsläufig mit eingeschränkt hätten, was ich nicht ertragen kann. Und ich bin der, ich werde eher sauer von uns beiden, glaube ich, und deswegen wäre ich eher ausgezogen, wütend. Aber auch mit diesem Stock und dem Tuch hinten dran, weil man auch so Filme aus so Comics kennt. Warum nicht einen Rucksack auf einfach? Rucksack war eine relativ frühe Erfindung. Und warum haben die den Stock, ich dachte, man benutzt den Stock zum Gehen. Kennst du doch, diesen typischen Stock, hinten über die Schulter, hinten dran hängt dieses Tuch mit dem Lember-Sprot. Aber ich würde den Stock als Gehstock nehmen und oben an den Gehstock den Beutel dran machen. Weil wenn du den so über die Schulter machst, ist der Hebel ja maximal gross und du hast maximal viel Gewicht auf deinen Arm. Nee, ich glaube eben nicht. Das ist wie so ein Seilzug. Also deine Schulter wirkt wie ein Seilzug und du kannst leichter Lasten heben. Aber wenn der Abstand zwischen Schulter und dem Beutel gross ist. Ja, du darfst keinen R darf aber keinen 10-Meter-Stock nehmen. Nimm einen kleineren Florentin. Wie lang ist ein Stock? Eineinhalb Meter ist so ein guter Stock. Klar, aber wenn du den vorne weiter nach vorne nimmst und vorne anfasst, dann kannst du wieder gegenhebeln. Das war eine Zeit. Das müssen schon echt Experten gewesen sein. Ja, ja, ja. Aber ich hatte heute ganz, ich dachte mir heute, weil, ich hatte heute nicht so mega viel zu tun. Und du hast geschrieben, hey, lass uns eine Viertelstunde früher treffen, aus etwaigen Gründen. Und ich habe geschrieben, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich es schaffe. Ja, und ich wusste, dass du wenig zu tun hast. Und ich dachte mir, was denkt Stefan jetzt? Was dachtest du, warum ich es wahrscheinlich nicht schaffe? Ich dachte, du hast einen Tag, ich dachte, du schläfst ungefähr bis 12, 1 Uhr, so was, bleibst im Bett liegen. Dann machst du nichts, dann kriegst du plötzlich Nachrichten von mir, wirst du aktiviert, merkst dann, dass du noch Dinge machen musst, wie Einkaufen gehen. Tatsächlich dachte ich, du hast dann alle Termine, die du hattest, oder Einkaufen gehen, alle Pflichten, die du hattest, auf das Ende des Tages, auf das Ende des freien Tages geschoben. Und deswegen konntest du nicht. Tatsächlich war mein Tag zu gut geplant, als dass ich die Waschmaschine so aktiviert habe, dass ich genau kurz bevor ich gehen muss, um pünktlich hier zu sein, die Waschmaschine entleeren kann. Und dann, und das ist wirklich der grösste Vertrauensbruch seit Brutus-Dolch-Attacke, dass nämlich bei der Waschmaschine steht, noch fünf Minuten, noch vier Minuten, noch drei Minuten, noch zehn Minuten. Noch vierzehn Minuten. Ich hab dir vertraut! Du warst mein einziger Verbündeter!
Und ich weiß nicht, wie dieser Betrug zustande gekommen war. Wann kam in diesem Zeitraffer der Wahnsinnigkeit meine Nachricht rein?
Deine Nachricht kam, als ich geguckt habe, noch 20 Minuten.
Du kannst zu früh kommen und ich so ...
Auf gar keinen Fall.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es schaffe.
Wütende Sprachnachricht.
Nein!
Meine Spülmaschine check ich überhaupt nicht,
wo wir gerade bei waschenden Maschinen sind.
Ich habe nämlich eine Maschine, die ist sehr alt und funktioniert auch nicht so richtig. Andauernd kommen fremde Leute in meine Wohnung, die diese Waschmaschine checken wollen, so eine komische Servicefirma. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob ich da irgendwie einem Scam unterlaufen bin und das ist einfach eine komische Sache. Und diese Waschmaschine, die ist aber noch funktionsfähig,
weil diese Leute die instand halten,
diese fremden Menschen.
Wie oft kommen die? Einmal täglich?
Lächerlich häufig. Nein, also nicht einmal täglich,
aber schon so wöchentlich. Und dann habe ich da,
nein, die kommt wirklich einmal im Jahr.
Keine Ahnung warum. Und dann mache ich da halt Geschirr rein und es ist halt immer unterschiedlich
und mache dann halt diesen Tab rein,
mache die zu und drücke auf an. Immer die gleiche Einstellung. und dann rechnet die sich aus, wie lange gewaschen werden muss. Wirklich? Je nachdem, welches Geschirr drin ist? Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe manchmal aus Spaß einen Stein reingemacht, weil ich wissen wollte, was, und es verändert aber nicht die Länge. Der rechnet sich irgendwas, wie die Sonne gerade zum Mars steht oder so, rechnet das, bezieht das ein in die Länge des Waschens. Und da steht immer 148. Und da denke ich mir, okay, das ist eine sehr konkrete Zahl. Wie kommst du auf 148? Mache ich einen Teller raus, mach die wieder zu? 148. Verstehe es nicht. Kann mir irgendjemand auf der Welt erklären, warum es so fucking lange dauert, Geschirr zu waschen? Hund, zwei. Zweieinhalb Stunden fast. Ist das wahnsinnig, diese Frage so zu stellen? Da wird Wasser drin rumgespritzt. Ich spritze meinen Teller zwei Stunden lang mit Wasser. Das ist doch völliger Quatsch. Ich habe für jedes Mal einen Dankestanz auf, wenn ich die Waschmaschine aufmache und alles sauber ist. Bist du wahnsinnig, das so zu stellen? Sei doch froh, das ist doch ein Geschenk Gottes, dass du die Waschmaschine aufmachst und du holst einfach sauberes Geschirr raus. Es glänzt. Weißt du, was da drauf ist? Ein gebackenes Chicken Tikka Masala von einem Jahr. Es geht nicht in meinen Kopf rein wie eine Maschine, die ja nicht wirklich laut ist. Die ist nicht wirklich laut, wie das die sauber bekommt. Du kannst mir nicht allen Ernst erzählen, als wenn du in deinem Leben noch nie eine Spielmaschine gesehen hättest. Und jemand fragt dich, hey, wie lange dauert es, dass eine Maschine dein Geschirr wäscht? Hättest du gesagt, 20 Minuten. Du hättest nicht gesagt, zweieinhalb Stunden. Auf gar keinen Fall. Komm mir nicht so. Kann sein. Beste Idee der Welt, eine GoPro in die Spielmaschine reinmachen. Und guckt es euch an, wir wollen nicht zu viel verraten, aber holy shit, da kommt was plötzlich raus, wo man denkt, was? Habe ich schon mal erwähnt, aber ich dachte bis zu diesem Video, dass die Waschmaschine randvoll mit Wasser läuft. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Echtlich? Wie eine Waschmaschine? Nee, die Spülmaschine. Nee, aber wie eine Waschmaschine, die läuft dran voll mit Wasser. Nee, ich dachte, die Spülmaschine, deswegen habe ich auch bis jetzt Todesangst, die aufzumachen. Warum haben die kein Fenster? Warum sagt die Waschmaschine, easy, ich bin transparent, ihr könnt reinschauen in mich, ich habe nichts zu verbergen. Hey Leute, ich habe nichts zu verbergen, Backofen, schaut rein. Komischerweise, die einzige Maschine, die ein Fenster hat, darf verschwinden Socken. In einer Waschmaschine, wo man nicht reingucken kann, verschwindet auch nichts. Im Backofen wird noch nie was verschwunden. Mikrowelle, alles da. Hat ein Fenster auch. Hat ein Fenster. Alles hat ein Fenster, nur die Spülmaschine nicht. Stimmt, die Spülmaschine sagt, nope. Hey, was dir drin vorgeht. Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, langsack. Ist wie so ein shady Typ am Bahnhof. Hey, ich besorge dir das, aber du darfst keine Fragen stellen. Du kriegst es sauber, okay, das ist der Deal. Du kriegst es sauber, aber stell keine Fragen. Und was machst du? Langsam. Ich hab gesagt, keine Fragen, okay? Okay, ich hab gesagt, keine Fragen. Ich mach's dir in 148 Minuten. Warum 148?
Das ist wirklich eine Frage.
Das sind so strange Dinge. Meine Waage,
wenn ich mich draufstelle, sagt die erst eine viel zu hohe Anzahl an Kilogramm,
dann eine viel zu wenige Anzahl an Kilogramm,
dann die exakte Anzahl an Kilogramm, glaube ich.
Aber so rum ist es besser.
So rum erst viel, dann wenig.
Bei mir ist es oft so, ich hatte...
Bei mir ist es halt irgendwie, ich hatte keine Ahnung, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Komma sechs, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Komma neun, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Komma acht. Wie viel wiegst du? Hast du echt Probleme mit deinem Gewicht? Nee, ich glaube, es ist 86,5. Ich bin schwerer als du. Aber es ist wirklich, du hast so 86,5, 86,9, 86,8, 86,9 und denkst dir, wo war die 5 nochmal, gib mir die 5 nochmal, 86,8, 86,7 und denkst dir so, nee, nee, nee, wenn das den ganzen Tag dauert. Warum sollte das überhaupt austariert werden müssen? Weil du veränderst dein Gewicht ja nicht. Naja, du atmest ja. Ja, Luft. Du atmest ja Helium. Wie jeder normale Mensch, der auf der Waage steht. Naja. Ach ja, okay. Wir müssen kurz über unsere Seite sprechen, die seit geraumer Zeit einfach, und wir haben uns auch entschieden, das Problem nicht zu beheben, aus einem Grund. Ich weiß nicht, Florentin hat gesagt, das passt schon, weil augenscheinlich hört ihr uns ja gerade noch, weil ich bekomme keine Beschwerdemails mehr rein. Ja, aber auch die Beschwerdemails laufen über die Webseite. Ach so. Das ist schon clever gemacht. Von uns. Es ist so, als ob wir das Projekt langsam beendet hätten, ohne selber davon zu wissen, dass nichts mehr von dem, was ihr gerade sagt, nach aussen dringt. Im Falle eines Problems wollen wir keine Informationen mehr bekommen. Wir glauben noch beide, dass es wieder so eine WP-Sex-Nummer ist, wie diese eine Tabelle, die sich mal in unserer Website gehackt hat. Wir sind im Grunde nur ein unangenehmes Telefonat dafür entfernt, diese Website wieder freizuschalten. Das Telefonat war so eklig wie Kondome kaufen. Und wie lautet Ihre Domain? Podcast minus UFO. Das war auch so unangenehm, als ich Paypal anrufen musste. Es sind Banker, es sind verkackte Finanzgenies. Wie heissen sie mit Vornamen? Aber jetzt Stefan Tietze, da steht hier nicht. Ich heisse mit Vornamen Das Podcast-Ober. Ja, da ist vielleicht das Problem.
Okay, wollen wir mal anrufen? Komm, wir rufen mal an. Hast du eine Nummer von WordPress? Wer ist denn das nochmal? Das Auto. Oder? Nee. ...und uns während der Wartezeit mit weiteren Informationen zu ihrem Anliegen zu versorgen.
Ah, der Berger! Oder? Nee. Radeberger. Ein Radeberger. Das ist ein Synkronsprache auf jeden Fall. Mitarbeiter zu warten. Erst wenn ein Auto alle... Okay. Aber warte, wer ist das? Soll ich sagen, was wir aufnehmen? Bruce Willis? Ist das Bruce Willis? Hallo, Tiese, schönen guten Tag. Und zwar haben wir ein Problem mit unserer Website. Die ist seit geraumer Zeit einfach down, und wir wollten mal fragen, woran das liegt. Haben Sie Ihre Kundennummer für mich? Unsere Kundennummer? Einen Moment.
Oder den Domainnamen?
Ne, den Domainnamen haben wir. Das ist podcast-ufo.fail.
Schau mal, einen Moment.
Das ist ein unüblicher Websitename.
Also ich bekomme eine Webseite, das ist podcastufo, der Podcast zwischen Asasner, zum Beispiel Show und TV und Stefan Dietzer. Ja, wirklich jetzt? Einen Moment. Bei uns steht nämlich,
wir rufen uns auch gerade parallel auf, und da steht, diese Präsenz ist derzeit nicht verfügbar.
Störung F5. Störung F5. Ja, jetzt ist wieder da. Aber das ist uns ein bisschen zu haarig.
Unsichere Registrierungsfunktion auf puffopedia.de, puffopedia.de, ne?
Hat offene Posten, die zu lange ausständig waren oder so?
Ne, eigentlich nicht. Ne, das ist doch gut, dann passt doch alles.
Ja, dann vertrauen wir Ihnen mal, dass es funktioniert alles. Cool, vielen, vielen Dank. Wir sollten immer so etwas auch mal probieren, was finde ich oder so, dann aus dem Plan ausgebucht, also über das Mobilfunknetz. Das ist immer so die Gegenprobe, ob irgendwas am lokalen Netzwerk gerade nicht passt oder so, vielleicht Route Firewall. Dass Sie es hier blockiert haben. Ja, genau. Ja, okay, alles klar, machen wir. Vielen, vielen Dank. Gerne. Danke, tschüss. Ey, aber das war mega strange, ey. Ja, okay, alles klar. Ey, wirklich, wir haben sie aufgerufen und während des Telefonats haben wir es refreshed und dann ging's wieder. Das hatte ich nämlich auch mal. Da muss irgendwas passiert sein. Der hat irgendwas gemacht. Vor allem, warum wusste er mit unsicherer Registrierung auf Puffopedia? Warum wusste er das plötzlich? Weil über dieselbe ... Geh mal auf Puffopedia. Aber das muss doch bei denen, wie so eine Arznei, wie so eine Krankenakte, muss da ja drinstehen, dass Puffopedia mal ein Problem war. Ja, Puffopedia ist auch immer noch ein Problem, denn Puffopedia.de gibt es nicht mehr, das ist komplett kaputt. Puffopedia.info ist das, wo die Puffepedia momentan ist.
In der Krankenakte steht, Puffepedia.de verstorben.
Ist Puffepedia.de langsam und siechend dahingehacht.
Okay, aufgrund Problemen mit der Unsicherheit abmeldet.
Jetzt wird Puffepedia.de nur noch umgeleitet auf Puffepedia.info.
Ja, so viel zu internen Problemen, die euch nicht interessieren.
Aber naja, jetzt funktioniert es ja wieder.
Oh, jetzt haben wir die Möglichkeit, direkt Kommentare vorzulesen, weil wir nämlich bis jetzt noch nicht auf der Seite waren und Kommentare noch nicht lesen konnten. Das heißt, vielleicht können wir jetzt ein paar Kommentare mit einbeziehen von ein paar glücklichen Leuten, die davon profitieren. Von Themen, die wir vor einem Jahr besprochen haben. Aber jetzt kann ich leider leider wieder auch nicht drauf. Ist wieder down? Nee, ich habe nur glaube ich kein Internet mehr. Vielleicht ist das das Problem. Ich glaube, bei den meisten technischen Dingen sind wir auch das Problem einfach. Bleiben Sie dran. Oh fuck, ey. Bleiben Sie dran. Der Podcast geht gleich weiter. Wir sind gleich wieder für Sie da. Ich merke gerade, dass ich unter den acht Webseiten, die bei Google angezeigt werden, eine Pornoseite habe. Es ist bei mir schon so weit, dass ich ... Aber was ist deine Pornoseite? Na, ich habe ... Kann man nicht sagen. Ich habe Google, also von den acht Webseiten habe ich Google, dann YouTube, dann Deutsche Bahn, dann Reddit, dann die Pornoseite, dann Amazon und dann Sparkasse. Ich habe Zweitbrowser, Pornobowser. Ja? Ja. Und Tor. Gab's nicht die Idee von Chrome, dass die automatisch in den Inkognitum-Modus wechseln? Kann sein. Ich hab gestern ein AMA gelesen, von einem Schüler, einem Highschooler, der eine Porno-Seite aufgebaut hat, ein Start-up. Funktioniert wie ein Nine-Gag. Also mit Pornos, mit einem Feed oder Reddit. Und der Porno mit den meisten Upboards am Tag landet halt oben. Und deswegen hast du so eine Topside quasi, eine Porno-Pornoseite mit Gifs und so, eine Hotpage. Ganz interessant. Und da gibt es einen Button, wo du draufdrücken musst, einfach, und dann werden alle Pornos, alle Pornoinhalte, selbst die Werbung, wird in Pokémon-Gifs umgeändert. Wie genial ist das denn? Du hast einen Shortcut, auch an der Tastatur, und du kannst oben auf den Tast drücken. Und wenn dann irgendwie die Schwester ins Zimmer läuft, hast du zwar immer noch deinen Schwanz ausgefahren, aber du hast zumindest überall, du oranierst zumindest nicht mehr zu Pornos, sondern zu Pokémon. Und die Frage ist, ob das besser ist. Aber okay. Aber es ist die Frage, ob das funktioniert, weil es ja sehr unterschiedliche Geschmäcker bei Pornos gibt. Ich weiß nicht, ob das da auch so die einen, die das eine mögen, mögen das andere. Aber das ist ja auch in den Fetisches. Alleine kannst du ja auch noch mal in den Subreddits kannst du auch noch mal nachforschen. Interessant. Unsere kleine Internet-Ecke. Sex-Ecke. Ey, wir haben ein Weihnachtsgeschenk für euch, kann man sagen. Also auch ein Weihnachtsgeschenk für uns, weil wir Cash, Cash, Cash bekommen. Und weil es auch die letzte Folge ist vor Weihnachten. Und weil es die letzte Folge ist. Wir machen eine Weihnachtspause. Okay, gut. Ich könnte noch drei Wochen, aber augenscheinlich nicht mehr. Du, Schüffoern, du, ich bin weg. Powder. Ja, wir haben uns nämlich gedacht, wir sind soweit, wir wagen uns raus, mal ausserhalb unserer Kleines Kämmerlein, wir machen mal die Rollladen auf, wir lüften mal durch, wir stehen auf, wir machen das Fenster auf, gehen aus dem Fenster, dieser imaginäre Raum hat keine Tür, und wir spielen zwei Live-Shows in Köln und Berlin, das Podcast UFO Live! Live hebt ab 2018, es ist soweit. Heißt die Tour so, wir heben ab 2018? Ich glaube nicht, ich glaube, da kriegen wir massive Copyright. Wie unangenehm. Wir waren doch zuerst da, oder? Wir heben ab? Locker. Seit Folge 1 machen wir das. Der Song ist nicht so alt. Aber jetzt fragen sich bestimmt viele, ich will dabei sein, wie geht das? Also, wir haben einen Vorverkauf. Ihr könnt Karten kaufen auf einer Website, die wir euch dann bekannt geben werden, am Freitag. Wir laden die Folge gleich noch hoch, heute ist Mittwoch. Ihr könnt am, oder morgen, am Donnerstag, ich will dir diese Tür offen lassen. Und dann könnt ihr am Freitagmorgen um 12 Uhr, damit alle Bescheid wissen, wir werden es auch nochmal als Tweet raushauen, und bei Facebook, aber damit alle Bescheid wissen, um 12 Uhr am Freitag ist der Vorverkauf start. Da, wo alle in der Schule sind oder arbeiten müssen. Genau, da, wo ihr am wenigsten könnt. Wo die Arbeitslosen am meisten belohnt werden. Genau, wir wollen die Arbeitslosen Loser bei uns jetzt haben, weil sonst fühlen wir uns schlecht und müssen deliveren. Freitag 12 Uhr beginnt der Kartenvorverkauf, also greift lieber zu, wir haben keine Erfahrung damit, wir wissen nicht, wie lange Karten verfügbar sind, ob ihr da irgendwie am Sonntagnachmittag noch irgendwie vorbeischlendern könnt oder ob das innerhalb von Sekunden weg ist. Wir haben keine Ahnung. Sehr interessant, das zu beobachten, das ist alles für uns neu. Und natürlich wird es auf diesen Live-Shows ein fantastisches Programm geben mit tollen Gästen, mit tollen Gästen, mit Stefan Tietze ist dabei und der Rest ist noch offen, wir wollen ja auch nicht zu viel. Damit wir uns, für euch das, also damit wir jetzt nicht irgendwie falsche Erwartungen wecken, also ihr kommt dann da in so eine Halle, das sind ungefähr 300, 400 Leute und dann ist es wie so ein Public Viewing, vorne ist ein großer CD-Spieler, so ein Ghetto-Blaster und da wird eine Folge angemacht, eine neue Folge. Keine alte Folge, aber eine neue Folge. Zwei T-Shirts minimum. Jeder muss mindestens zwei T-Shirts kaufen. Genau, zwei T-Shirts minimum kaufen. Und nicht, dass wir da sind, also nicht, dass ihr denkt, wir wären da. Vorne steht einfach ein großer Ghetto-Blaster, der eine neue Folge abspielt. Dann können alle gemeinsam lachen. Das ist doch ein Podcast-Live-Event. Das ist ein Erlebnis. Voll. Ey, ich bin gespannt. Ich bin auch gespannt. Es wird wahrscheinlich so, ob man das sagen kann, so März, April sowas in der Richtung sein. Ich muss das sogar sagen, weil sonst können Leute, es ist im März und April. Ich weiß die genauen Daten, 13. April? Aber wir haben noch ein paar Monate Zeit und wir schnaufen erstmal durch jetzt über Weihnachten und bereiten eine fantastische Show vor. Ich glaube, wir haben uns darauf geeinigt, dass wir die dann nicht veröffentlichen, die Live-Shows. Das heißt, es sind exklusive Folgen, die nur die Leute mitbekommen, die sich auch...
Ich würde sagen, wenn die gut werden, haben wir es noch raus.
Ja, also wahrscheinlich nicht.
Also wahrscheinlich exklusiv.
Aber wenn ihr dabei sein wollt, also wir würden uns freuen, euch da begrüßen zu dürfen.
Ja.
Ja, genau.
Ach ja, und als kleines Weihnachtsgeschenk natürlich noch obendrauf, haben wir auch noch eine kleine Überraschung. Und zwar wollen wir unseren Shop ein bisschen erweitern. Also neben Warnwesten, Defibrillatoren, Teddybären, kommt jetzt die Podcast-Sufo-Pfeffermühle. Für alle, die auch ... Das ist wie so ein Chibo-Gottanlock mittlerweile. Ich glaube, dieses TCM von Chibo ist auch als Podcast gestartet. Und irgendwann kriegen wir auch so gute Produkte, bieten wir an. Der DVD-Brenner, der Podcast-Sufo. Das Podcast-Sufo-Curry-Gewürz. Greift zu. Wir kaufen so ganz viele Restbestände auf, rucken da einfach unser Logo drauf und ballern das raus. Bei Lebensmitteln hörst du auch irgendwie auf. Man will auch nicht Comedy-Carry haben. Das ist nur noch, da hat er Spaß auch auf. Ich glaube, Comedy hört beim Essen auf. Haltet die Augen offen, wir werden euch auf jeden Fall informieren und posten, aber spart schon mal. Heißt auch, der Spreadart-Shop macht dicht, oder? Kann man, glaube ich, so sagen. Deswegen kauft jetzt noch so mal fleissig ein, Weiss auf Weiss, die Klassiker, lasst ihr euch noch mal raus, bevor es dann weitergeht. Mässtet schon mal euer Sparschwein, bis es dann losgeht und ihr vielleicht für Freunde und Bekannte auch mal ein bisschen reingreift und uns richtig schön Geld um die Ohren schleuen können. Nee, die sehen jetzt besser aus. Die sehen jetzt endlich mal gut aus. Das andere war ein bisschen eine Frechheit. Wer hat auch nichts daran verdient, muss man auch sagen, so ein bisschen Weil wir es verbockt haben. Wir haben vergessen, auf Provision den Haken zu machen. Herr Spreadshell sitzt auch zu Hause in seiner großen Mansion, wie die Bluthunde unten im Kerker warten auf den nächsten Gast. Und er sitzt da so in seinem, wie Mr. Burns, stelle ich mir vor, sitzt dann so in seinem Sessel, weil wir vergessen haben, die Provision anzuhalten. War das auch nicht bei Twitter irgendwie so? Coole Idee, viele Leute mögen es, aber whoops, wir verdienen kein Geld. Oh nein, shit! Da haben wir gar nicht dran gedacht. Wir sind wie Twitter im Prinzip, kann man sagen. Ja, aber das wird tolles Jahr 2018 für das Podcast Ufo-Fans. Live-Events, wir wissen nicht, wie es dann weitergeht. Wir machen jetzt einfach mal zwei. Und dann gucken wir mal, ob wir das häufiger machen, ob wir das auch in anderen Städten machen. Wir wollen da ganz locker und unverkrampft rangehen. Wir wollen jetzt nicht die große Europatür ankündigen, sondern sagen einfach mal, wir gucken mal, ob uns das liegt, ob uns für unser Stil, ob für unsere Erwartungen das funktioniert. Und wenn nicht, dann nicht, dann bleibt es dabei. Aber wenn wir Bock haben, dann machen wir vielleicht mehr. Mal schauen. Genau, freut euch auf spannende Stunts und Lucie Feuerwehr. Wir haben noch keine Ahnung, wie konkret wir dieses Event veranstalten, ob wir einfach nur labern oder ob wir tolle Sachen vorbereiten oder irgendwie noch mal alte Videos zeigen von Bingy Sack Bu, ob's ein Bingy Sack Bu Live-Auftritt geben wird, all das. Ich finde, können wir Referate vorbereiten. Ja, so Impulsrefer. Ja, Impulsreferate, zwei Referate. Und aus dem Publikum darf auch einer ein Referat halten. Finde ich gut. Also bereitet alle mal ein Referat. Jeder, der kommt. Vielleicht kommt ihr dran, wie in der Schule. Wir wollten noch über Jim und Andy eigentlich sprechen, die Dokumentation. Stimmt, du hast Hausaufgaben aufgegeben. Ja. Ich habe den Film gesehen, also es geht nochmal um Andy Kaufman,
einen Comedian, der für seinen
exzentrischen und Performance-Art-Stil
bekannt war, der dann irgendwann gestorben
ist und der viele Comedians beeinflusst
hat, unter anderem Jim Carrey, der irgendwann
dann in einem Film Andy Kaufman
gespielt hat. Genau, Man on the Moon von
Milish Comedian. Genau, und sich mega in die
Rolle reinversetzt hat und auch während den gesamten
Dreharbeiten nie die Rolle gebrochen hat. Und darüber gibt es jetzt einen Dokumentarfilm, ein grosses Interview mit Jim Carrey und Jim and Andy heißt der Film auf Netflix. So, Stefan Tietze hat die grosse Weltverschwörung gekündigt. Wahnsinniger, also die Dokumentation ist doch unfassbar toll. Die Dokumentation ist gut, ich habe aber nicht ganz verstanden, warum du so krass begeistert warst.
Ich dachte mir, coole Sache, cooles Ding.
Mir hat es unfassbar gefallen, weil ich, also ich bin der festen Überzeugung, weil mir haben so viele danach geschrieben, oh, was ein furchtbares Arschloch. Und auch unser Kollege Jan Wübbermann hat es in dem Konkurrenzpodcast Fashion Flauschig auch besprochen und hat auch gesagt, tolle, okay Dokumentation, aber was für ein furchtbares Arschloch.
Was ein dummes Arschloch und wie unbewussten der war.
Ich behaupte, das ist natürlich, das ist kein Documentary, das ist ein Mockumentary.
Und ich behaupte, das hat er alles für das Dokumentationsteam vor Ort gemacht, halt einfach.
Der hat quasi die Rolle für das Dokumentationsteam, auch genau, das ist einfach ein gestageter Act,
der quasi das Werk von Andy Kaufman irgendwie weiterführen soll. Und der natürlich genau die Fragen aufwirft, wie die Andy Kaufman ja auch auf, irgendwie gab es dieses Konflikt mit dem Wrestler wirklich, haben die sich wirklich dann versöhnen wollen und wieder gezofft bei Letterman und so. Und es waren ja genau diese gleichen Plot-Point Punkte hat man ja auch dann wieder in der Dokumentation gesehen, nur halt in Person von Jim Carrey, was ich total genial fand. Und er hat einfach das Werk von Andy Kaufman so gut transportiert in diese Doku, dass man fast überlegt, man guckt gerade irgendwie eine Doku über Andy Kaufman mehr als eine Doku über Jim Carrey. Ja, man muss ja sagen, die Dreharbeiten wurden gefilmt und begleitet und dann war dieses Material ganz lange unter Verschluss, so wird es zumindest gesagt in der Doku. Ach, du bist nach den Credits geguckt? Ich habe bis nach den Credits geguckt. Die Dokumentation war ganz lange unter Verschluss, bis irgendein Dokumentarfilmer auch dann lange nach Dreharbeiten und so gesagt hat, wir gucken uns jetzt mal alles an und dann wurde das alles zusammengestückelt. Das heißt, wenn das alles ein geplanter Prank-Mockumentary wäre, dann ist das ein grosses Ding, weil das jahrzehntelang geschlafen hat. Ja, aber Andy Kaufmann hat gesagt, ganz am Anfang, ey, wenn ich keinen Bock mehr habe, dann werde ich einfach eine Krankheit erfinden, sowas wie Lungenkrebs oder so, und dann werde ich den Leuten sagen, ich bin tot. Und dann nach 20 Jahren komme ich wieder und tue so, als wäre nichts gewesen. Und dann hat er halt die Diagnose bekommen und es wie im Film hat ihm das niemand geglaubt, dass er Lungenkrebs hat. Und dann ist er noch zu diesem Wunderheiler irgendwie auf die Philippinen gereist und so, hat dann aber auch nichts gebracht, hat aber lächerlicherweise noch ein bisschen was gebracht und dann aber ist der Krebs zurückgekommen und er ist dann gestorben. Und dann dachte ich mir, ah, gucken wir mal, ob er gestorben ist, vielleicht ist jetzt 20 Jahre später und Jim Carrey kommt als Andy Kaufman 20 Jahre nach seinem Tod zurück in Form der Dokumentation. Nee, war hart nicht hingehauen. Schade, ich fand das eine gute Theorie, ich habe mich kurz gefühlt wie jemand, der das alles durchschaut hat, aber ich fand das ganz toll. Vor allem die Comedy, für die Andy Kaufmann steht, fand ich so atemberaubend toll. Weil er hat ja dann einfach, habe ich das letzte Woche schon erzählt, er hat ja The Great Gatsby vorgelesen bei einer Show. Und alle wollten halt, weil er war halt in dieser einen Sitcom Taxi, die alle toll fanden, er war gar nicht so. War halt nur seine Rampe zu einer Show, die er unbedingt mal machen wollte, irgendwo in New York. Und dann haben Leute gesagt, mach den Latka aus Taxi, mach den Latka aus Taxi. Und er hat gesagt, naja, nee, komm, nein, das darf jetzt nicht wahr sein. Und hat dann angefangen, The Great Gatsby vorzulesen, das ganze fucking Buch, vier Stunden lang, hat er auf der Bühne The Great Gatsby vorgelesen. Leute waren sauer,, die haben Ding geworfen, die sind gegangen irgendwann. Dann hat einer gesagt, komm, mach wenigstens diesen Act, den du machst mit dem Plattenspieler. Weil sein erster Act war, wo er dann mit zu einem Song gesungen hat bei SNL, und er hat gesagt, okay, dann hat er den Plattenspieler vorgeholt, mach den Plattenspieler an, und es läuft kein Song, sondern es läuft eine Aufnahme von ihm, wie er weiter The Great Gatsby vorliest. Wo ich mir denke, okay, das ist einfach, der Mann ist einem immer einen Schritt voraus. Der Mann ist einem, der Mann weiss, was du gerade über ihn denkst. Du denkst, der hat angefangen als so eine Art Anti-Humorist, hat Acts vorbereitet, die keine Acts waren offensichtlich. In der Zeit, wo man Dinge vorbereitet hat, bis zur Ekstase hat man Dinge geprobt und dann gemacht. Das war diese vorbereitete Fernsehkultur. Und er kam da rein mit Acts, die keine waren und die so halbgar waren, die jeder irgendwie in seinem Wohnzimmer für sich hergeprobt hat. Und er ja auch. Und die dann halt vor Publikum macht. Und plötzlich dreht er dann auf der Bühne aber immer diese Erwartungshaltung um, weil er genau weiss, dass das gerade ankommt wie jemand, der sich nicht vorbereitet hat, auf diesen Auftritt. Und dann dreht er die Erwartungshaltung um und bricht das halt dann immer nochmal, was ganz toll ist, er ist immer den Zuschauern einen Schritt voraus und bricht nie seinen Charakter. Und das hat Jim Carrey halt wenig fantastisch weitergetragen. Und auch dann, wie er hinter den Kulissen diesen Streit mit dem Wrestler halt angezettelt hat. Und ich habe mal geguckt, tatsächlich sind keine Nachrichtensendungen zu finden, wo er mit einer Halskrause bei den Dreharbeiten wegtransportiert wurde. Also das ist wahrscheinlich schon einfach nachgedreht worden für diese Doku, was ich ganz fantastisch finde. Und er ist einfach ein fantastischer Typ. Also Jim Carrey ist ein cooler Typ, wie er darüber spricht und was er für eine coole, was er für coole Sachen einfach aushaut. Ich meine, da hat uns auch ein User ein cooles Zitat geschickt, wo er halt sagt, muss ich mal raussurden.
Ich fand auch diese eine Story so cool, dass er mit seinem Durchbruchfilm, ich glaube Ace Ventura war das, und dann hat er einen Gehaltscheck für eine Million Dollar bekommen und in der Zeit ist sein Vater gestorben und sein Vater wurde beerdigt und er hat ihm diesen eine Million Dollar Scheck in die Hand gegeben
und der Vater wurde mit dem Scheck beerdigt,
ohne dass er ihn angelöst hat,
sein Geld für seinen ersten grossen Durchbruch.
Das macht schon einfach Spaß, diese Doku,
ich finde es ganz toll, vor allem auch für uns,
die auch Komödiebern.
Es ist super interessant, ich muss nur ganz ehrlich
sagen, dass gerade diese
Andy Kaufman Sachen, also das ist ja auch die Idee, aber es sind unglaublich schwer zugänglich. Es ist natürlich auch mit Zeit, es war eine andere Zeit, aber ich fand davon wirklich nicht viel lustig. Ich habe mir dann auch Auftritte von Andy Kaufman angeschaut und also ich glaube, das kann man auch nicht verstehen. Also fandest du das lustig? Ja, ich fand das. Ja, wirklich? Also ich fand diese Great Gatsby-Nummer hilarious. Aber die, also die Nacherzählung finde ich auch lustig und die Idee ist lustig. Aber die Vorstellung wirklich vier Stunden lang. Okay, das ist glaube ich Zeit. Das ist dann so ein Ding. So ist das und vor allem dann, er ist unglaublich hyperaktiv, unglaublich albern, trommelt dann auf seinen Kongass rum und rennt durch die Gegend und schreit. Aber diese Nummer, wo er am Anfang halt, wo er halt dieser ausländische Typ, The Foreigner, auftritt und dann ganz schlecht Leute imitiert, so nach dem Motto, hey, I'm Donald J. Trump und alle so, alle schon sauer werden im Publikum und dann plötzlich sagt er, okay, dann mach ich jetzt Elvis und er macht den perfekten Elvis, singt perfekt den Elvis, das macht schon Spaß. Also das ist vor allem, das ist ein richtig lustiger Act und deswegen, ich finde auch die Idee teilweise immer besser als dann die Umsetzung. Ich glaube, die geht in der Zeit ein bisschen verloren. Aber die Idee hinter seinen Werken finde ich mega gut. Das macht schon Spaß und das geht auch in einem Film auch gut. Cool. Auf. Darüber wollte ich wieder sprechen. Ich finde die Doku an, Jim und Andy, coole Sache. Coole Sache. Wir blicken auf ein Jahr zurück. Was ist dieses Jahr alles passiert? Wir waren wieder nicht beim Pumor Kongress. Na, nächstes Jahr. Seite war wieder down. Es wiederholt sich alles, das stimmt. Dostentlich hat sich alles wiederholt. Wir haben die 100 Folgen voll gemacht. Wir hatten Jan Böhmelmann zu Gast, endlich. Jan Böhmelmann war zu Gast, unser grosser Held. Folge 50 hatten wir, Folge 100 hatten wir. Ja, wir haben vieles Jahr. Folge 52 hatten wir, die nicht gelöschte Folge.
Ja, es ist viel passiert.
Es ist viel passiert, wir blicken auch viel zurück.
Was war dein Highlight?
Ich erinnere mich an nichts.
Ich fand da Vinci ist nach wie vor im Kopf geblieben.
Dumm Vinci, toll. Dumm Vinci, toll, gibt auch eine eigene Puffopedia-Seite für Dumm Vinci, schaut da mal vorbei.
Und geht generell mal auf die Puffopedia und schreibt da mal so ein paar kurze Artikel, neue Artikel, neue Seiten.
Ihr müsst auch nicht alles Content von uns, ihr könnt auch mal selber Content draufhauen, finde ich. Ballert mal was raus. Haut was raus. Ansonsten? Tipps für die Ferien? Kommt mal runter. Einfach mal entspannen. Hast du das Gefühl, die sind aufgedreht? Ja, schon ein bisschen. Kommt mal ein bisschen runter und erweitert mal ein bisschen euren Horizont. Macht mal Sachen, die ihr noch nie gemacht habt und schaut euch mal Filme an, die ihr sonst nie guckt. Hört Musik, die ihr sonst langweilig findet. Einfach mal ein bisschen einen kleinen Kredit geben. Einfach mal sagen, hey, ich höre jetzt einfach mal zwei Reggae-Alben. Ich finde geil, es gibt glaube ich nur einen Reggae-Alben. Ich hasse auch Reggae, deswegen dachte ich mir was ... Es gibt nur ein Reggae-Album mit zwei Songs, glaube ich. Ich dachte mir gerade, was müsste ich machen, wenn ich das machen würde, was ich hasse. Ich müsste mir Metal und Reggae anhören. Metal? Warum hast du Metal? Ich weiß nicht, ich kann das nicht leiden. Das ist nicht mein Energielevel. Ich bin eher so, ich mag Regen. Das finde ich entspannend, aber Metal ist mir zu aggressiv. Ich finde anstrengend so Transmusik. So mit wummernden Bässen und ausrastenden Synths. Das kann ich nicht ertragen. Das ist schwer auszusprechen. Synths. Und wie haben dir die Synths gefallen? Oh, ich fand die Synths im fünften Song am besten. Die Synths im fünften Song. Deswegen tanzen Transfans auch eher, als dass sie sich mit der Musik unterhalten. Sie reden nicht, die hören einfach laut Musik und machen tsch, tsch, tsch. Ganz strange. Ich hab mal für, hier für 1Live musste ich mal einmal los, da gab es diese Nacht, wo alle überall Partys waren und so, die 1Live-Nacht, und dann haben wir das von der Firma hier gefilmt und begleitet und da war ich plötzlich in so einer Party, wo auch die ganze Zeit so eine Musik lief und ich habe wirklich einfach Angst zustande bekommen, weil dann auch alle einfach auf Ecstasy waren oder eine andere Droge, die einen alle wahnsinnig in sich kehren lässt, aber wahnsinnig hyperaktiv machen lässt. Und dann stand halt einfach für sich in so einem furchtbaren, das war hier auch in Köln so ein Club, ganz dunkel, so ein Fabrikgelände. Und dann zwar überall Lichter, aber sonst ist das einfach immer noch ein Fabrikgelände. Und darüber stehen Leute so für sich, die einfach so tanzen, wie man alleine tanzen würde. Wie du halt, wenn du alleine tanzen würdest und dich nicht schämst vor Leuten, dann würde ich auch so tanzen. Und die so ganz ähnlich gekehrt sind, das Gefühl, du kannst die auch so umschubsen oder so. Die würden auf dem Boden einfach genauso weiter tanzen. Das wäre ihnen egal, das war eine ganz gruselige Sache. Das ist eine Kultur, die ich nicht so verstehe. Das müsste ich machen. Und damit Ich freue mich auf die nächste StefanPhase, dass wenn wir aus der Weihnachtspause zurückkommen, hat Stefan die Transphase. Ja, ähm, was sind meine Tipps? Nicht backen, lasst mal die ganzen Weihnachtssachen einfach fallen. Also hört auf, irgendwie keinen Tannenbaum holen und so, einfach mal, dass ich langfristig von Traditionen wegkommen, das finde ich schön. Kein Plätzchen backen und so, kein Weihnachtspulli anziehen, Silvester auch um zehn Uhr schlafen gehen und sowas.
Gut.
Das war mein Tipp.
Das war 2017 mit dem Podcast UFO, wir sagen Tschüss, das war Stefan Tietze.
Und das war Florian Hinwill.
Und wir heben ab, bis zum nächsten Jahr, macht's gut, bis dann.